hi I'm ray five chairman off the bluff
Community Board with Kelly Fewster from
the Blood Service Center we just want to
let Bluff residents and visitors to our
town know that Bluff Neal has a
designated area with dogs can be
exercised off feed this off lead area is
at the Ocean Beach reserve it's a place
where your dog can be off lead and run
around but the still needs to be under
control and respond to your commands and
just remember that if you're walking or
exercising your dog anywhere else a
bluff then if you must be on a leash at
all times unless the dog is detained in
your property this is to keep people
safe from unrestrained dogs but also to
keep our dogs safe from Motor Vehicles
and other dangers by heavenly and safely
on a lead and under control at all times
for more information about this or any
other queries related to dogs contact
the Animal Services team on to triple
one triple seven all right check out
council's website dub dub dub
icc govt TVNZ or call in to the bluff
service center